♫ Done away
♫ Done
♫ Away
- Okay, new idea.
We chill for a couple
of hours, they sing it.
Voices, harmony, mustaches.
Today, we're joining a
barbershop quartet for one day.
- I was formally trained
when I was growing up.
I sang in choirs for six years.
- I did musical theater growing up,
but mostly I just like to sing in the car.
- I used to take chorus in high school
and then when I'm drunk,
I will sing karaoke.
- I have no formal
singing experience at all.
I tried to get in the choir
and they wouldn't let me do it.
Mr. (beep), go to hell.
- I think it's gonna
be extremely difficult
to form a barbershop quartet in one day.
Especially because I
feel like I'm gonna be
the weakling in this group.
I love to sing, I'm not great with rhythm.
- I cannot read music.
Again, Mr. (beep), go to hell.
- I think once we get sound,
once we know what our parts are
and we come together as a
group, it will come together
really, really well.
- I'm Joey.
- I'm Jackson.
- I'm Jake.
- I'm Ryan.
- We're called the Newfangled Four.
Barbershop harmony is four
people singing together.
It can be all guys, it can be all girls.
It can be a mix.
And it's tight, close harmonies
so you're gonna need to know your notes.
We're gonna be learning a very
old classic barbershop tune
called By the Light of the Silvery Moon.
You're gonna be singing
it for all your coworkers.
- And it's too late to quit.
- The four different parts in
barbershop from the top down,
we go Tenor, Lead, Baritone, and Bass.
We got our bass.
- Hello, I'm bass.
- We have our lead.
- I'm lead.
- We have our baritone.
- I'll be the baritone.
- And our tenor.
- Yep.
- All right, let's do this, guys.
- One, two, three, four.
All your out.
(Joey moans)
♫ This is my face when
my soft palate raised
♫ That's crazy, this one's mine
- And Ben?
- Let's do a chord warmup.
All right, bass, you and me.
- Oh God.
- We're gonna go
♫ Ah, ah, ah, ah
All right, lead.
♫ Ha, ha, ha, ha
Baritones.
♫ Ah ah ha ha ha ha
Tenors.
♫ Ha ha ha ha ha
♫ Ah ha ha ha ha
- We did the thing.
♫ Watermelons yay
We're gonna jump right into this,
this is gonna be super, super easy.
- Okay, you keep saying that and then.
- Oh, shoot, I need a pitch.
- If the tenor doesn't know their part,
the whole thing falls apart.
- We could do it without the tenor.
♫ By the light
♫ Of the silvery moon
- One, two, three.
♫ Honey moon, honey moon, honey moon
- I want you to try it as far as you can
without the music in front of you.
- Then we say we want to spoon again,
call that an echo.
♫ I want to spoon
♫ The moon
- No, no, you can't
leave me on the last one.
- You did it on your own.
- God damn it.
- I'm proud of you.
- Yeah!
♫ We'll be cuddling soon by the silvery
♫ By the light, by the
light of the silvery
- Oh wait, I say moon, never mind.
♫ By the light of the silvery moon
- Whoa!
♫ There by the light of the silvery moon
♫ The moon
(crowd talks quietly)
- Hello, everyone.
How we doing today?
- [All] Good.
- All right.
Please welcome the Buzz Cuts.
(crowd cheers)
(harmonica tone sounds)
♫ By the light
♫ Of the silvery moon
♫ I want to spoon
♫ To my honey I'll croon love's tune,
♫ Honeymoon
♫ Keep a shining in June,
♫ Your silvery beams
will bring love dreams
♫ We'll be cuddling soon
♫ By the silvery moon
♫ There by the light of the silvery moon
♫ The moon
(crowd cheers)
- We finished it.
- We did it.
- Wow, survived y'all.
- I thought we did great.
I thought we did really well,
better than I would have expected.
- I think we did the
best we could in a day
for people who aren't good at this,
but I feel like it's
such a specific art form.
I don't think I did a good job.
- Yeah, I know.
- It was fun.
- It was a lot of--
- Even though I wanted to
throw up the whole time.
- To just be able to be
in front of our coworkers,
try something new that
we haven't done before.
It was exciting, I enjoyed it.
- Yeah.
- If I see in the hall.
- We might have a little karaoke moment.
- Walk in the hall and hit a
♫ Love's groove
- Y'all, we did it.
- We did.
- [All] One, two, yeah!
(soft music)